hay posiciones encontradas pero espacio
para llegar a un acuerdo es lo que
asegura la delegación ucraniana después
de esta quinta ronda de negociaciones
mañana rusos yo creo que nos van a
seguir hablando este diálogo se
interpreta positivamente hoy incluso ce
lens que ha asegurado que este país su
cráneo tiene que mentalizarse de que en
un futuro no se va a poder adherir a la
otan sobre el terreno la guerra continúa
los ataques continúan sobre todo en kiev
y los suburbios están disparando contra
edificios de civiles y para proteger
precisamente a ellos a los civiles el
alcalde ha decretado un toque de queda
de 36 horas de forma continuada hoy en
que también se ha recibido la visita de
tres primeros ministros el primer
ministro de la república checa- de
polonia y de eslovenia para mostrar su
apoyo a este país